اين
[موسيقى]
ذهبت ابتسامتك الجميله يا بوراك وما سبب
كل تلك الدموع التي تنهمر على خديك وتختلط
بكل حرف ينطق به فمك الشاف التركي المحبوب
يصدم محبي لقد جاءتني الطعنه من اقرب شخص
لي احتال علي والدي وسرق كل شيء كنت املكه
والاب يرد لا تصدقوه انه ممثل محترف وتلك
الدموع التي ترونها هي دموع التماسيح ما
هي علاقه زلزال تركيا بازمه الشيف بوراك
مع والده وما حقيقه افعال بوراك الخيريه
التي قدمها لمتضرر الزلزال وغيرهم وهل
احتال عليه ابوه بالفعل كما يزعم ام ان
للحقيقه وجه اخر لتعرف اجابه كل تلك
الاسئله اليك القصه زلزال بوراك يبدو ان
زلزال تركيا الشهير لم يكن مجرد هزه ارضيه
في مدينه اسطنبول فحسب بل كان هزه عنيفه
في حياه الشيف بوراك ايضا فبعد هذا
الزلزال كان بوراك في مقدمه قافله
المسعفين قدم للضحايا الف وجبات اللحم
والفواكه وكل اصناف الغذاء واحضر لاطفالهم
كميه ضخمه من الالعاب المسليه ليخرجهم من
حاله الرعب التي كانت تسيطر عليهم كل هذا
من ماله الخاص ثم ظهر في فيديو وهو يبكي
ليقود حمله واسعه من اجل مساعده متضرر الى
لقائلا ارجوكم من يملك القدره على
المساعده ان لا يبخل بها حتى الان هناك
ناس لا يزالون تحت الالقاب الوضع كارثي
كثير من رسائل الاستغاثه تاتي ولكننا لا
نستطيع فعل اي شيء ارجوكم ليفعل كل منكم
ما بوسعه من اجل هؤلاء المساكين تلك
الكلمات التي قالها بوراك بصوت مختلط بسيل
من الدموع ادمت قلوب كل من سمعها وراه وهو
ينطق بها ولكن من الناحيه الاخرى كان هناك
شخص غير راض عما فعله بوراك بل استشاط
غضبا من ذلك التصرف هذا الشخص هو اسماعيل
والد الشاف بوراك والذي حاول منع نجله من
دعم متضرر الزلزال قائلا له توقف عن اهدار
الاموال الضخمه في مثل هذه الجهات سيتاثر
وضع الشركه كثيرا بما تفعل ولكن بوراك
تجاهل امر والده واستمر في صرف الاموال
الضخمه الاعداد الوجبات ودعم المتضررين
ليقوم الاب بالانتقام وتبدا حرب شرسه بينه
وبين نجلاء فماذا فعل الاب
سامنعك حتى ولو بالاحتيال فوجئ بوراك
بوالده قد باع حقوق ملكيه سلسله مطاعمه
لرجل اعمال بقيمه واحد واربعين مليون
دولار الشاف بوراك يتجرد من كل شيء ويواجه
شبح الافلاس ليظهر في فيديو ويفضح ما فعله
والده قائلا لا تنخدع باللصوص الذين
يستغلون اسمي لم يعد لدي اي مطعم في
اسطنبول باستثناء الذي في وادي اسطنبول
والدفاع كل شيء لصالحه واصبحت فارغ اليدين
انتشر الفيديو كالنار في الهشيم الملايين
من سكان العالم يتعاطفون مع الشاف المحبوب
ويهاجمون اسماعيل اوزديمير الذي التزم
الصمت ويصبون عليه اللعنات لكن لم يتحمل
اوز كل هذا الهجوم كثيرا ليخرج عن صمته
ويشرح القصه من زاويه اخرى قد تقلب
الطاوله على نجله فماذا قال الاب
لص شهره بدموع تماسيح
نفا اوزديمير كل التهم التي وجهت اليه
واعلن ان زوجته السابقه والده بوراك هي من
يقف وراء شحنه ضده وان بوراك نفسه ليس
ملاكا هبط من السماء بل هو لص شهره ويحاول
استغلال كل شيء حتى وان كانت مصائب الغير
من اجل تحقيق مصلحته فقد قال الاب بوراك
يقول للناس لقد خدعني والدي لا علاقه لي
باي شيء كان دائما يساعد في مناطق الزلزال
من اجل الدعايه فقط لقد اكتسب زينه امه
وقال ساعادي والدي اما بالنسبه لاحتياله
على بوراك قال اوزديمير لم يكن هناك اي
شيء باسمي بوراك قبل عامين ما هذا ان صح
كلام اوزديمير فهذا يعني ان بوراك لم يكن
يمتلك شيئا في الاساس حتى يسلبه منه والده
وان كل ما كان باسمه هو في الاصل ملك
لوالده الذي رفض ان نجله في الاعمال
الخيريه من اجل جمع اللايكات حسب تعبير
اوزديميان اي قذيفه وجهتها يا اوزديميار
لجمهور نجلك الغفير والسؤال لكم مشاهدينا
هل ترون ان بوراك ملاك وقع ضحيه اب مستغل
ام انه شيطان يستغل مصائب الغير من اجل
الدعايه لنفسه كما قال ابوه اخبرونا في
صندوق التعليقات